nos dice es más alto o más bajo y se
refieren por supuesto de estas imágenes
por ejemplo nos dice la ballena es y hay
que completar la respuesta puede ser más
alta en este caso más alta que tres
bloques o más baja que tres bloques y
por supuesto de la imagen podemos ver
que es un botón no sé cómo dos bloques
más altos que esta torre verdad entonces
la ballena es más alta que tres bloques
por otro lado tenemos una ardilla y hay
que compararla con la misma pila de
bloques verdad dice la ardilla es más
alta que tres bloques o más baja que
tres bloques y por supuesto vemos que la
ardilla más o menos tiene una altura de
dos bloques así que la ardilla es más
baja que tres bloques y ahora hay que
concluir dice entonces la ballena es más
alta que la ardilla y creo que ya no se
ve
la ballena es más alta que la ardilla o
más baja que la ardilla y bueno pensemos
la ballena es más alta que estos tres
bloques y los tres bloques son más altos
que la ardilla entonces la ballena tiene
que ser más alta que la ardilla vamos a
ver es correcto ahora dice es más alto o
más bajo y dice el zorro es más alto o
más bajo que tres bloques y por supuesto
aquí podemos ver que es más bajo que
tres bloques verdad es como de dos
bloques y luego nos dice el pony es más
alto o más bajo que tres bloques y por
supuesto el pony es más alto que tres
bloques verdad es mucho más alto luego
concluimos que el zorro es más alto o
más bajo que el pony pues bueno si el
zorro es más bajo que estos tres bloques
y el ponías más alto que los tres
bloques pues el zorro tiene que ser más
bajo que el pony verdad así que vamos a
comprobar la respuesta y es correcto
vamos con otro ejercicio más tenemos el
mismo tipo de ejercicio verdad dices más
alto
ahora bien la oveja es más alta más alta
o más baja que tres bloques pues por
supuesto se ve que es más alta que tres
bloques verdad y por otro lado dice el
castor es más alto que tres bloques o
más bajo que tres bloques y aquí parece
que son de la misma altura pero en
realidad el castor es ligeramente más
bajo que tres bloques verdad por lo
tanto si en la oveja es más alta que los
tres bloques y el castor es más bajo que
tres bloques entonces la oveja tiene que
ser más alta que el castor vamos a ver y
es correcto vamos con un último
ejercicio este ejercicio es distinto
dice arrastra las líneas hacia arriba o
hacia abajo ordena las de la más corta a
la más larga coloca la línea más corta
hasta arriba entonces aquí en este
ejercicio podemos intercambiar el orden
de las líneas y el punto es colocar los
de la más corta a la más larga entonces
vemos que esta es la línea más corta
verdad
línea más corta y debería ir hasta
arriba luego debe ir la segunda más
corta verdad esta línea es mucho más
larga que esta otra por lo tanto esta es
la que debe ir en medio verdad y ahora
sí ya están ordenados de la más corta a
la más larga vamos a ver y es correcto